.
* Dynamische Musik *
Er ist seit 17 Jahren Polizist.
Der Beruf ist so vielseitig
wie kein anderer.
Sie haben
gerade ihre Ausbildung begonnen.
(Schreiend) Hey!
Das eigene Leben
ist natürlich das höchste Gut.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Eben kam eine Meldung: "Eine Frau
mit Kindern schreit umher."
Das ist die Eingangsmeldung,
die wir bekamen.
Für Yves Chappuis
von der Polizei Basel-Landschaft
sind Blaulichtfahrten Alltag.
Zentrale 1101 vor Ort,
hier ist noch die Sanität.
Wir wissen noch nicht,
worum es geht. Ich gebe Bescheid.
Wie viel hat dieser Alltag
mit den Vorstellungen seiner jungen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zu tun,
die neu in den Beruf einsteigen?
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Vielleicht ein Krampfanfall.
Sie hatte Thoraxschmerzen.
Er hat kurz gedrückt,
aber sie war bewusstlos- Okay.
Könnt ihr mir helfen,
sie auf die Bahre zu legen?- Ja.
Habt ihr noch keine weiteren
Erkenntnisse, worum es geht?- Nein.
Der erste Eindruck ist,
dass es etwas Medizinisches ist.
Könnt ihr alle etwas zurückstehen,
bitte?
Vielen Dank.
Entschuldigung, können Sie
etwas zurück ... Zurück, bitte.
Nein, jetzt gehen wir
hier auf das Bett.
Kannst du sie unter dem Arm halten?
Eins, zwei, drei.
Okay, gleich auf die Seite legen.
Auf diese Seite.
Also, wer gehört zur Familie?
Wir alle.
Das ist meine Schwester.
Darf ich kurz mit Ihnen sprechen?
* Ein Kind weint. *
Können Sie mir erklären,
was passiert ist?
Im Schlaf haben wir
sie schreien gehört.
Darauf gingen wir hinein.
Sie sagte uns,
sie habe einen Druck auf dem Herzen.
Sie hat dann immer wieder geschrien.
Michèle, alles gut.
Es ist gut, die Sanität ist hier.
Ich versuche mich zu beruhigen.
- Versuche dich zu beruhigen.
Also, die Patientin
ist im Rettungswagen und das ist ...
Die Tochter.
- Nein, die Nichte.
Ich meine die Nichte.
Sie hyperventiliert und ... ja ...
Sie ist recht aufgeregt.
Wir sehen so
ein medizinisches Ereignis öfters.
Wenn es für sie das erste Mal ist,
ist es klar,
dass sie aufgeregt ist
und Angst um die Person hat.
Sie sind die Schwester?
Ich bin ihre Mami.
Bitte?
- Ihr Mami.
Von wem sind sie das Mami?
Das sind alle meine Kinder.
Sie ist meine Tochter.
Sie, die im Sanitätswagen ist?
- Ja, das ist meine Tochter.
Das ist Ihre Tochter?
- Ja.
Haben Sie einen Ausweis?
Darf ich den sehen?
- Ja.
Vielen Dank.
Bleiben Sie bitte hier stehen.
Beruhigen Sie sich.
Es ist alles okay.
Ah, 2000 ...
Wie alt ist sie?
20?
- Der Jahrgang steht da.
2001 - okay.
Das ist der Ausweis Ihrer Frau.
Alles okay, Mami.
Sie schauen schon.
Ist das das erste Mal?
- Ja.
So ... so ...
so wie jetzt ist es das erste Mal.
Okay.
Vielen Dank an alle.
- Das ist schon recht.
Hat die Frau wirklich
ein medizinisches Problem?
Oder wurde sie
Opfer eines Verbrechens?
Das wird nun im Spital abgeklärt.
Was dabei herauskommt,
wird Yves Chappuis nicht erfahren.
Für ihn ist der Fall erledigt,
die Nachtschicht geht weiter.
Das Luzerner Seetal.
Hier lassen
die Polizei Basel-Landschaft
und zehn weitere Kantone
der Zentral- und Nordwestschweiz
ihren Nachwuchs ausbilden.
Die Interkantonale Polizeischule
Hitzkirch
hatte erste Coronavirusfälle
und befindet sich darum
in einem Teil-Lockdown.
Die praktische Ausbildung
wie etwa Schiessen
findet weiter vor Ort statt,
alle theoretischen Fächer müssen
im Fernstudium erarbeitet werden.
Heute liegt Spannung in der Luft.
Ich bin eine langsame Schiesserin.
Ja, aber nimm dir Zeit.
Wir haben kein Zeitlimit.
Ja, dann ist es egal.
Meistens stresst es einem, wenn
die anderen schon geschossen haben.
Ich finde, wenn ich lange ziele,
bringt es nichts.
Doch.
- Schon?
Meistens beim letzten Schuss,
beginne ich heftig zu zittern.
Schweisshände
habe ich auf jeden Fall.
Und das Adrenalin
schiesst in meine Blutbahnen ein.
Ich bin definitiv aufgeregt.
Heute ist die Schiessprüfung.
Jana Stierli
von der Polizei Basel-Landschaft
hat die letzten Wochen
nicht immer ins Schwarze getroffen.
Entsprechend gross
ist die Anspannung.
* Akzentuierte Töne *
Rhythmus gut, noch einmal.
Wer heute durchfällt,
darf die Prüfung einmal wiederholen.
Wer ein zweites Mal durchfällt,
fliegt raus.
Ihr dürft den Karton abreissen.
Jemand soll neue Scheiben holen.
Das war die Aufwärmrunde.
Ja, jetzt
waren die Schüsse nicht schlecht.
Die Technik
kann noch etwas besser werden.
Es darf so bleiben.
Vielen Dank.
Zum Auswerten, damit es für alle
klar ist. Denkt daran:
Der ganze Kreis gibt bereits Punkte.
Der ganze Kreis inklusive
des Anrisses.
Ich sage euch,
wann nachladen und wann entladen.
Konzentriert euch auf euren Auftrag.
Der Rest ergibt sich dann.
Kreis links,
ein Schuss ohne Zeitlimit.
Feuer frei.
Meine Waffe ist noch nicht geladen.
- Ja, ladet.
Jetzt gilt es ernst.
Dann könnt ihr starten.
* Akzentuierte Töne *
Oben links, ein Schuss, Feuer frei.
Der Instruktor sagt jeweils,
wohin der nächste Schuss gehen soll.
* Schuss *
Und er sagt,
wie lange gezielt werden darf.
Noch einmal wiederholen,
ein Schuss, 3 Sek.
Achtung!
* Mehrere Schüsse *
Ich habe sicher bestanden,
so wie es aussieht.
Jetzt kommt es noch auf die Note an.
Aber bestanden - ich bin froh.
Also, einen.
Dann fehlt einer.
Zwei, drei, vier, fünf.
56 minus fünf macht 51.
Was gibt das für eine Note?
4,5?
Ich sage es dir gleich.
Ich muss nachschauen.
- Ja.
Zukleben, bitte.
Die Nerven haben gehalten.
Ja, definitiv - 51 von 56.
Doch, da hat sich
seit letzter Woche etwas getan.
Ich bin stolz auf mich.
* Lachen *
Später erfährt sie: Note 5.
* Mehrmaliges Klicken *
Die Nachtschicht
ihrer Kollegen im Dienst geht weiter.
Ohne Mampf kein Kampf.
Es wurde zur Tradition, dass ich zur
Nachtschicht eine Wähe mitbringe.
Das kann Yves gut.
Wenn er sonst schon nichts kann.
Meier.
Ich sage nichts.
Nein, nein,
ich kann auch sonst kochen.
In den Pausen darf man sticheln,
im Einsatz müssen sie einander
ihr Leben anvertrauen.
Im Extremfall
ist der Kollege für dich da.
Er ist meine Versicherung.
Gerade, wenn es darum geht
dich zu schützen,
wenn dich z.B. jemand angreift,
festhält oder noch schlimmer.
Die Nachtschicht beginnt um 20.30 Uhr
und endet um 6.30 Uhr.
Inzwischen ist weit nach Mitternacht.
So um 1, 2 Uhr,
wenn draussen nichts mehr läuft
und keine Aufträge reinkommen,
beginnt man runterzufahren.
Dann wird der Körper müde
und es wird zäh.
Und dann, so um 5 Uhr
geht es relativ schnell
bis es 6 Uhr ist.
Aber die Zeit nach 1, 2 Uhr
möchte man sich lieber hinlegen.
Am besten ist es,
wenn du um 23 Uhr einen Fall hast,
der bis um 2, 3 Uhr geht.
So geht die Nacht
gefühlt schneller vorbei.
Als Neuling unterschätze man
die unregelmässigen Arbeitszeiten.
Diese seien belastend, für einen
selber, aber auch für das Umfeld.
Die Patrouille geht weiter.
* Sanfte Klänge *
An der Polizeischule in Hitzkirch
beginnt jeder Tag um 7.30 Uhr
und endet um 16.10 Uhr.
Aufmachen.
Und sie macht ganz auf.
- Ist gut?
Ich schaue zuerst durch den Spalt,
wenn die Tür aufgeht.
Wenn sie öffnet,
sehe ich schon viel mehr.
Mach Licht!
Jetzt mache ich hier Licht.
Im Notfall
natürlich schneller als jetzt.
Sobald ich Licht gemacht habe,
spiegle ich auf.
"Vorgehen innerhalb des Objektes",
heisst das Ausbildungsmodul.
Bis hierhin.
Jana Stierli schleicht sich an.
Ein Klassenkamerad versucht,
sie zu sehen.
Ei, ei, ei.
Er hat mich schon gesehen.
Noch weiter nach hinten.
Also bis zu dieser Ecke?
- Ja, genau.
Wenn jemand hinausschaut
und hierherschaut,
sieht er dich.
Ja, vorhin ist das passiert.
- Ja, genau, sehr gut.
Ja, stimmt.
Jetzt so, dass nur der obere Teil
des Gesichts hervorschaut.
Okay.- Sodass du möglichst
nicht gesehenwirst.
Okay.
- Sehr gut.
Das könnte man z.B.
bei einer Geiselnahme brauchen.
* Dumpfe, akzentuierte Klänge *
Versuche einmal,
beides gleichzeitig zu machen.
Aber dann komme ich
zu weit nach vorne.
Es ist viel besser jetzt.
- Ehrlich?
So kommst du weniger nach vorne.
Beim realistischen Aussendienst
ist die Situation so,
dass die gelernten Muster,
die man in der Polizeischule kennt,
teils nicht so eintreffen.
Es kommt zum Glück
nicht immer bis zur Schiesserei.
Es wird aber das Maximum trainiert.
Im realistischen Alltagsleben
als Polizist
hört diese Schwelle
zum Glück vorher auf.
Aber man muss bereit sein
für Eventualitäten,
sodass es gegen Abend
noch Luft hätte.
Schau mal.
- Polizeimeldung.
Ein gesprengter Bancomat,
diese Nacht.
Oh, Ja.
Es gab ein riesiges Loch
in der Wand.
Durch das Loch kann man
in den Tankstellenshop gehen.
Das gab sicher
eine heftige Detonation.
Da kommen kaum
Kleinkriminelle infrage.
Das müssen Profis gewesen sein -
vermutlich aus Frankreich.
Man weiss auch nie, ob das Spreng-
mittel vollständig gezündet wurde.
Wir nähern uns nicht,
bevor die Spezialisten das prüften.
Das eigene Leben
ist natürlich das höchste Gut.
Man geht nirgendwo hin,
wenn man das Gefühl hat,
man könne sich verletzen.
Da kennt man seine Grenzen.
Baselland ist ein Grenzkanton.
Die Polizei hat es darum regelmässig
mit Tätern
aus dem umliegenden Ausland zu tun.
Diese agieren oft sehr professionell
und sind äusserst brutal.
Fahr gleich hierher.
Beim direkten Kontakt heisst das
für die Polizei: höchste Vorsicht!
Die Patrouille ist zufällig
am Tatort vorbeigefahren
und will ihn
sich kurz persönlich ansehen.
Dieser Beruf
ist so vielseitig wie kein anderer.
An einem Tag haben wir einen
Überfall auf einen Bancomaten,
dann gibt es Medizinisches,
bei dem man helfen kann.
Manchmal kann man bei Tieren helfen.
Dann hat man wieder Schalterdienst,
bei dem man einen Betrug aufnimmt.
Freud und Leid zusammen in geballter
Ladung, wenn man es nicht erwartet.
Das macht es spannend.
Automatenbomber sind immer
häufiger in der Schweiz unterwegs.
Schnell, risikoarm,
aber eine grosse Beute.
Solche Aktionen haben den klassischen
Bankraub mit einer Waffe am Schalter
weitgehend abgelöst - in ganz Europa.
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
Was konntet ihr drinnen machen?
Sie haben das Geld
mit der Geldmaschine gezählt.
Von Hand haben sie die angebrannten,
verklebten oder zerfetzten
aussortiert.
Sie müssen zählen,
wie viel Bargeld übriggeblieben ist.
Also beschädigte Noten?
- Genau.
So können sie eruieren, wie viel
Geld die Gauner erbeutet haben.
An solchen Tatorten sind sie selten.
Viel häufiger haben sie
z.B. mit häuslicher Gewalt zu tun.
Häusliche Gewalt
erleben wir im Dienst immer wieder.
Ich kann aber nicht sagen, ob das
wöchentlich oder monatlich passiert.
Einmal hat man eben das Pech,
dass man dazukommt.
Ein anderes Mal
trifft es eine andere Patrouille.
Mich wühlen Situationen auf,
an denen Kinder beteiligt sind.
Wenn sie vor Ort sind
und dabei zusehen müssen,
wenn wir dort auftreten.
Ich finde es schrecklich,
wenn das ein Kind miterleben muss.
Heute geht es um HG,
also häusliche Gewalt,
an der Polizeischule in Hitzkirch.
Rund 20'000 Fälle gibt es
pro Jahr in der Schweiz,
über 50 pro Tag.
Was machen wir zuerst?
- "Halt, Polizei" rufen.
Was macht ihr mit dem zusammen?
Einsatzmittel.
Die Gewalt stoppen. Einverstanden?
Das ist der primäre Auftrag von uns:
Gewalt stoppen!
Dann klingeln und klopfen,
je nach Situation eben.
Dann passiert das: Die Tür geht auf.
Was ist euer nächste Schritt?
Wovor ich euch abrate und abhalten
würde, ist ... Kommt etwas näher.
Wenn die geöffnet wird,
den Fuss hineinzustellen.
Ich sage nicht, dass es falsch ist.
Okay,
Sinn und Zweck habe ich erfüllt.
Aber das Problem: Die Tür kommt
mit einer Geschwindigkeit zurück,
an der die Zehen keine Freude haben.
Die Variante ist,
dass ich den Fuss hier hinstelle.
Wenn die Tür zugeht, drücken wir
dagegen, damit sie offen bleibt.
Einverstanden?
Wenn mir das nicht gelingt,
schiebt es mich hinaus.
Nach der Theorie
dann die praktische Übung.
Hörst du das?
- Ja.
* Unverständliche Rufe *
Frau Weidle?
- Kommen Sie herein.
Polizei Baselland, Guten Tag.
Dürfen wir hereinkommen?- Ja.
Bleiben Sie dort hinten, bitte.
Legen Sie die Flasche weg.
- Polizei Baselland.
Nando Wüthrich muss versuchen,
den betrunkenen Mann,
gespielt von einem Mitschüler,
zu beruhigen.
Nicht berühren, bitte.
Was soll das?
- Ich kann auch anders.
Du auch. Geht nach Hause.
Gehen Sie bitte ...
- Nein, nein, weg da.
Es kotzt mich an. Hey!
Ganz ruhig.- Gebt mir
wenigstens meine Weinflasche.
Loslassen.
Ich muss trinken.
- Lassen Sie die Flasche los.
Wenn Sie sich die nächsten 5-10 Min.
benehmen können,
sprechen wir wieder darüber.
Aber jetzt ist Ihre
und unsere Sicherheit ...
Nichts Besseres zu tun heute,
oder was?
Wir sind bei der Arbeit.
Grüezi, Frau Gerelinger.
- Ja?
Caro, wer ist das?
Neue Übung, neue Rollen:
Nando Wüthrich ist nun der Schläger.
Seine Mitschüler müssen ihn
korrekt über seine Rechte
und Pflichten aufklären,
bevor sie ihn befragen dürfen.
Gehen Sie bitte rein.
- Hast du die Polizei angerufen?
Das spielt jetzt keine Rolle.
Gehen Sie jetzt rein.
Bitte schön, Herr Derendinger.
* Lachen *
Wenn ich Sie nun also
Auskunftsperson, bzw. als Opfer,
wegen den Tätlichkeiten
gegen sie einvernehme,
sind Sie nicht
zur Aussage verpflichtet.
Sie müssen sich auch nicht selbst
oder ihnen nahestehende Personen
belasten.
Wenn Sie eine Aussage machen,
muss sie der Wahrheit entsprechen.
Sie dürfen uns nicht anlügen oder
andere Personen falsch beschuldigen.
Das Vorgehen und die Formalitäten
werden durchgespielt - immer wieder.
Das ist auch ohne
die Emotionen eines Ernstfalles
eine grosse Herausforderung.
Die Aspiranten sollen lernen,
ihr theoretisches Wissen
in praktischen Übungen anzuwenden.
Die Realität kommt noch früh genug.
Man wird sich daran gewöhnen.
Beim ersten Mal ist es extrem viel.
Wir haben es heute Morgen rein vom
taktischen Aspekt her angeschaut.
Aber bei all den Formularen
und rechtlichen Schritten
sind sehr viele Überlegungen
dahinter,
die korrekt
ausgeführt werden müssen.
Mir persönlich fehlt einfach
noch eine gewisse Sicherheit.
Ein Stück weit Sicherheit, damit ich
genau sagen kann, was Sache ist,
ohne das Gesetzbuch
zur Hand zu nehmen.
Alles abzudecken ist hier
die grosse Schwierigkeit.
Nando Wüthrich ist der Sohn
eines Kantonspolizisten.
Darum lernte er schon als Kind, wel-
che Folgen Verbrechen haben können.
Er sei auch schon zu schnell
gefahren, sagt er,
ansonsten habe er eine weisse Weste.
Ich würde mich schon
als korrekten Bürger bezeichnen.
Ich halte mich einfach an die
Regeln, wie es jeder machen sollte.
Und ja, ich versuche mein Bestes.
Nach den praktischen Übungen
in Hitzkirch
geht sein Tag
jeweils im Homeoffice weiter.
Die Theorie muss er sich
wegen der Coronapandemie
zu Hause erarbeiten -
in einer blitzblanken Wohnung.
Ich glaube schon, dass meine auf-
geräumte Wohnung mich widerspiegelt,
v.a. auch meine Partnerin.
Wir beide haben es gerne ordentlich,
damit wir wissen,
wo unsere Sachen sind.
Und so ...
So haushalten wir auch.
Wir räumen alles dorthin,
wo es hingehört.
So müssen wir nichts suchen.
Hallo.
- Hey.
Hallo, Schatz.
Ça va?
Seine Freundin ist Heilpädagogin.
Hattest du einen guten Tag?
- Ja, er war sehr anstrengend.
Für sie passt Nando Wüthrich
bestens in eine Uniform:
Er sei der geborene Polizist.
Er hat gute,
kommunikative Fähigkeiten.
Er kann sich klar ausdrücken.
Ja, er ist sehr
verantwortungsbewusst.
Manchmal überkorrekt. Nein, nein.
Und auch emphatisch.
Das ist sicher auch wichtig.
Und da ist sicher
auch der sportliche Aspekt.
Seine Energie,
die er positiv einsetzen kann.
Ich kann auf die Schnelle einen
Gourmetschmaus herbeizaubern.
Nando hat gerne viel Fleisch
und ich habe gerne ...
... am liebsten gar kein Fleisch.
Aber wir haben einen
guten Kompromiss ausgehandelt:
In der Regel
nur qualitatives Fleisch.
Ausser, wenn es um Hotdogs geht -
dann nicht.
Seine Freundin sei geduldiger als er,
sagt Nando Wüthrich.
Er könne
dafür besser mit Stress umgehen.
Er bleibe auch in schwierigen
Situationen ruhig und stets korrekt.
Eine zentrale Eigenschaft
für einen Polizisten.
Denn die Gesetze gelten auch für sie.
Übertreten sie diese,
müssen sie damit rechnen,
dass es jemand beobachtet.
Bilder einer Überwachungskamera:
Ein Luzerner Polizist tritt 2013
morgens um 4 Uhr
einem rumänischen Einbrecher
immer wieder gegen den Kopf.
Was er nicht wusste:
Es wurde alles gefilmt.
Der Vorfall hatte nicht nur für
den Elitepolizisten Konsequenzen.
Der interne Umgang
damit trug am Ende mit dazu bei,
dass der Kommandant
seinen Hut nehmen musste.
Polzisten werden aber auch
immer wieder zu Unrecht kritisiert.
Yves Chappuis erlebte das
nach diesem Einsatz vor drei Jahren.
(Lachend mit schwerer Zunge)
Entschuldigung, wer sind Sie?
Herr Chappuis.
- Chappuis?- Genau.
Eine Betrunkene beschimpfte
in einer Bar Gäste, warf Gläser,
verletzte jemanden
und weigerte sich zu gehen.
Einfach etwas Distanz.
- Rieche ich schlecht?
Nein, ich möchte nicht zu nahe sein.
Wo wohnen Sie?
- In meinem Körper.
Das ist das Ding mit der Haut drauf,
irgendwie Haut rundherum.
Haut ringsum, sie sei irgendwie
das grösste Organ.
Sollen wir Ihnen einen Taxi rufen?
* Prusten *
Entschuldigung, da haben es
andere wahrscheinlich nötiger.
Wir bleiben
nicht mehr lange mit ihnen hier.
Entweder Sie organisieren etwas
oder wir bestellen Ihnen ein Taxi.
Sie können hier
nicht länger bleiben.
Was mache ich jetzt mit dem Velo?
- Das können Sie morgen holen.
Das bleibt jetzt besser stehen,
damit kommen Sie nicht nach Hause.
Ich will ja nicht unfreundlich sein.
Ich auch nicht,  aber ... äh ...
Aber ich werde
zunehmend unfreundlicher,
wenn Sie jetzt nicht einsteigen.
- Was einsteigen?
Weil Sie nicht einsteigen.
- Hä?
Wie lange wollen wir das hier
noch machen?
Entweder steigen Sie ein, wir fahren
sie nach Hause und es ist erledigt.
Option B:
Ich legen Ihnen Handschellen an
und sie kommen nach Sissach
in die Ausnüchterungszelle.
Haben Sie mich verstanden?
Also, steigen Sie ein, bitte.
(Nachdrücklich)
Steigen Sie jetzt bitte ein!
Warum?
Ganz einfach,
weil wir jetzt Handschellen anlegen.
Wie bitte?
Oh! Jetzt sind Sie sehr nah.
Achtung, wenn die Brille kaputtgeht,
bezahlen Sie sie.
* Sie schreit hysterisch. *
Hör mal!
* Langanhaltender Schrei *
Hey.
(Betrunkene)
Jetzt reicht es dann aber.
Ja, jetzt reicht es definitiv.
* Alle sprechen durcheinander. *
Hol den Kabelbinder.
(Frau) Du stirbst,
verdammt noch mal, du Sau!
Ficke dich im Fliegen,
ich ficke dich in den Arsch!
(Seufzend) Ja, ja.
Du verdammte Drecksau.
Als sie wieder nüchtern war,
kamen massive Vorwürfe.
Die Sache liess sich ohne Juristen
lösen Ð meist reiche ein Gespräch.
Man kann ihnen dann erklären,
wie ihr Verhalten war.
Und wir begründen noch einmal,
warum wir so reagierten.
Aber man kann
nie alle glücklich machen.
Nach 17 Jahren habe ich das gelernt.
Man kann nicht immer
alle glücklich machen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Jana Stierli darf zum ersten Mal
mit auf Patrouille Ð
in zivil und entsprechend ihres
Ausbildungsstandes noch unbewaffnet.
Im Moment hat sie keine Schule.
Sie ist in einem einwöchigen
Praktikum in ihrem Polizeikorps.
Ich bin noch nicht aufgeregt. Aber
neugierig auf das, was uns erwartet.
Zwei erfahrene Polizisten
nehmen die Aspirantin mit.
Jana, jetzt müssen wir uns
bei der Zentrale anmelden.- Ja.
Das machen wir mit dem mobilen Ding.
- Ja.
Die Zentrale hat gesehen,
dass wir uns angemeldet haben.
Ja.
Und, dass wir eine Freipatrouille
sind.- Okay.
Wenn wir keinen Einsatz haben,
sind wir präventiv unterwegs.
Die Patrouillenfahrt
ist eigentlich
unser Nebeneinsatz,
wenn wir
nicht aktiv von der Zentrale
an einen Einsatz geschickt werden.
Endlich ein Einsatz.
Jetzt kannst du sagen:
"Birs Zentrale, 1101 vor Ort."
Birs Zentrale von Birs 1101 -
wir sind vor Ort.
Guten Tag.
- Grüezi, Polizei Basellandschaft.
Dürfen wir hereinkommen?
- Natürlich.
Ein Rentner hat die Polizei gerufen.
Er habe Bargeld und Steuerunterlagen
im Haus gehabt.
Und plötzlich
sei beides verschwunden.
Sie haben uns angerufen?
Ja, es ist so:
Ich ging hoch und sah,
dass die Schublade des Sekretärs ...
... offen stand.
- Alles ist weg.- Okay.
Darin waren 2'500 Fr.
und die Steuerunterlagen.
Auch die Versicherungsunterlagen
sind weg.
Das ist auch weg?
- Ja.
Sie können hinaufgehen
und nachschauen.
Sie sagten,
dass das gestern passierte.
Das war am Mittwoch.
- Okay.
Ich habe die Tür
immer abgeschlossen - immer.
Jetzt schauen wir,
ob es irgendwelche Spuren gibt.
Das Problem ist, dass wir
momentan noch keine Ahnung haben,
wie die Person hereinkam.
Und es muss zwischen
11 und 11.15 Uhr passiert sein?
Am Mittwoch.
- Ja.
(Rentner) Darin hatte ich
2'500 Fr. für die Steuern.
Die Steuern betragen 2'500 Fr.
Die lagen hier bereit.
Hatten sie das bar?
- Das hatte ich in Bargeld.
Sonst hat es nirgends,
z.B. eine Unordnung oder so etwas?
Nein, nur die Schranktüre war offen.
Die habe ich geschlossen.
Und dann noch den Heimatort?
- Ja, genau.
Frankreich.
- Ja, Frankreich.
Dann schreibe ich
einfach Frankreich.
Wo kann man Sie am besten erreichen?
Über das Haustelefon?
079 ...
Und es kamen Ihnen noch Dokumente
abhanden?- Alle Dokumente.
Von den Steuern?
- Ja, von den Steuern.
Ich habe die Herdplatte abgestellt.
Ah, das ist gut.
- Nicht, dass der Reis anbrennt.
Das ist einwandfrei.
- Wunderbar.
Alles Gute ihnen allen.
- Adieu.
Danke für den Besuch.
Bitte, gern geschehen.
Die Polizei will nun
mit der Tochter Kontakt aufnehmen
und dann entscheiden,
wie es weitergeht.
Ja, es ist relativ ruhig.
Es wäre schöner,
wenn etwas los wäre.
Aber es ist gut für alle,
die draussen sind,
dass es ihnen gut geht.
Ja, es hat zwei Seiten.
Und wenn gar nichts läuft,
machen sie Verkehrskontrollen.
Grüezi, Sie dürfen
noch das Licht einschalten.
Das stellt automatisch ein,
aber es spinnt gerade.- Okay.
Mit solchen Kontrollen sammelt
die Polizei keine Sympathiepunkte.
Ihm sei es nie um Macht gegangen,
sagt Yves Chappuis.
Er wollte niemanden zurechtweisen
und Bussen verteilen.
Er wollte für Gerechtigkeit sorgen
und Freund und Helfer sein.
Mit diesen Fotos und Videos
seiner Ausbildung
seien schöne Erinnerungen verbunden.
Es sei der Anfang
eines neuen Lebensabschnitts gewesen.
nach seiner Lehre
als Landmaschinenmechaniker.
Ich war im Alltag, nach dem Ein-
stieg ins Berufsleben, überrascht,
welche grosse Rolle ein Polizist
in der Bevölkerung innehat.
Er wird angeschaut,
ernst genommen
und es wird
sehr viel vom Polizisten erwartet.
Nämlich, wenn man vor Ort ist, dass
man das Problem erkennt und löst.
Wenn die Polizei gerufen wird,
hat man die Erwartungshaltung,
dass sie das Problem
zu lösen versucht.
Das ist am Anfang
sehr schwierig umzusetzen.
Genau.
Was ist der Rechtsaufbau?
Zuerst kommt die Bundesverfassung.
Das sind Kompetenzen
zwischen dem Bund und Kanton?
Und ...
- Korrekt.
Genau ... ja.
Dann kommt das öffentliche Recht.
Aber auch noch das private Recht.
Jana Stierlis Partner unterstützt sie
auf dem Weg zu ihrem Traumberuf.
Die beiden wissen, dass
viele erfahrene Polizisten sagen,
die unregelmässigen Arbeitszeiten
seien eine Belastung
für sie und ihr Umfeld.
Wir lernten uns so kennen.
Ich habe vorher
in der Pflege gearbeitet.
Dort ist es normal,
dass man am Wochenende arbeitet,
dass man Frühschicht,
Spätschicht und Nachschicht hat.
Mein Umfeld kennt das,
du kennst das.
Darüber mache ich mir keine Sorgen.
Es hat auch vorher gut geklappt.
Ich denke,
das wird weiterhin gut klappen.
Ich werde das
in meinem Beruf sicher auch haben.
Dann werden wir Wege finden.
Bis jetzt haben wir das
recht gut gemacht.
Wenn sie eine Nachtschicht hatte
oder wenn ich irgendwo
bis spät in der Nacht war ...
Wenn es nicht gepasst hat,
hat es eben nicht gepasst.
Sonst haben wir
immer Kompromisse gesucht.
Sie könne sich durchsetzen,
sagt ihr Umfeld,
sie sei fokussiert und willensstark.
Sie sei aber auch kommunikativ
und empathisch.
Also eine
Idealbesetzung als Polizistin,
auch wenn allen klar ist, dass
der Beruf nicht ungefährlich ist.
* Dynamische Musik *
Der Einzige, der ein wenig Angst
hat, ist der Vater meines Freundes.
Er macht sich etwas Sorgen,
weil ich im Polizeiberuf bin.
Man muss im Berufsalltag eben auch
mit gewissen Risiken rechnen.
Auch Nando Wüthrich ist im Moment
nicht an der Polizeischule,
sondern im einwöchigen Praktikum.
Lagebesprechung vor dem Einsatz.
Dann Kellereinbrüche.
Das ist im Moment ein aktuelles
Thema, v.a. in Allschwil.
Stellt man bei diesem Fall fest ...
Es gibt doch den Modus Operandi?
- Genau.
Das Vorgehen
ist immer wieder gleich.
Hier hat man festgestellt,
dass das Vorgehen immer gleich ist.
Es gelingt dem Täter
immer wieder auf irgendeine Weise
in die Mehrfamilienhäuser
zu kommen.
Dann geht er in den Keller.
Bei den Holzlattenverschlägen
hat es Schlösser dran,
die er mit einer Trennscheibe
oder einer Säge durchtrennt.
Kaum hat die Nachtschicht begonnen,
kommt auch schon die Meldung:
Der Serieneinbrecher
habe vermutlich wieder zugeschlagen.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Du kannst jetzt näherkommen.
Vor Ort dann die Gewissheit:
die bekannte Methode.
Es dürfte wieder der Gleiche sein.
Das wurde
mit einer Trennscheibe gemacht.
Das Problem ist,
dass wir aufgrund der Struktur
keine Spuren sichern können.
Hast du ein Foto von hier gemacht?
- Ja.
Von ganz nah? Denn das wurde
mit der Trennscheibe geöffnet.
Es ist wieder
der gleiche Modus Operandi. - Ja.
Was waren es für Velos, Rennvelos?
Das eine war ein Gravel Bike,
ein 3T.
Ich habe Fotos davon.
Dieses hier ist eines davon.
Dann haben wir zweimal Rennvelo.
Kann ich hinein?
- Ja, Sie können rein.
Spurentechnisch
kann man das vergessen.
Das ist das Formular
mit den Personalien.
So vergisst du nicht,
was wir alles entgegennehmen müssen.
Hier ist es so, dass wir die ein-
fachen Personalien entgegennehmen.
Ist der Keller mit Ihrem Namen ange-
schrieben oder hat er eine Nummer?
Ich glaube eine Nummer.
- Das schauen wir uns an.
Die Polizisten können nichts tun.
Ein Fall für die Versicherung.
Als Nächstes werden sie
als Verstärkung angefordert.
Anwohner meldeten
verdächtige Jugendliche,
die kontrolliert werden sollen.
Du bist dem nun relativ ausgesetzt.
Lass dich einfach nicht provozieren.
Irgendeinen Grund gibt es, warum wir
sie genauer anschauen sollen.
Jetzt nehmen wir
einen nach dem anderen zu uns.
Weil es so viele sind
und sie vermutlich klientelmässig
bei uns schon bekannt sind,
sind wir auch mehr Leute als sonst.
Du kannst alles hier hinlegen.
Er ist dort, die anderen beiden
sollen dort drüben bleiben.
Er kontrolliert ihn dort.
Seine Aufgabe
ist momentan nichts anderes,
als seinen Kollegen zu sichern,
damit er ihn kontrollieren kann
und er keinen Mist macht.
Er muss im Moment
diese beiden beschäftigen.
Und meine Aufgabe
ist in erster Linie, neben dir,
auch den Rundumblick zu haben.
Wir sind bei vielen ein Feindbild.
Das ist einfach so.
Wir versuchen immer,
so weit deeskalierend zu wirken
wie es möglich ist.
Also nicht irgendwo noch triggern,
damit es am Schluss nicht eskaliert.
Vielfach ist es so, wenn du
einen oder zwei kontrollierst,
ist es ein Phänomen, dass sich
andere, Unbeteiligte, einmischen
oder sich verbrüdern
und miteinander verbinden.
Das ist dann
der gefährliche Moment.
Keiner hat Drogen dabei,
alle dürfen gehen.
Zum Schluss kommen sie
noch zu einem Selbstunfall.
Das Auto liegt ja im Graben.
Warte, nicht weiterfahren.
Hier hat es Spuren.
Okay, speziell, nicht wahr?
Zentrale -
1302 ist Allschwil vor Ort.
Von wo kamen Sie gefahren?
Von dort sei er gekommen - und könne
sich das Ganze nicht erklären.
In diese Richtung machen wir Fotos.
Denn aufgrund der Spuren ...
Es ist hier brutal hell.
Aber nur vom Anfahren im zweiten
Gang landet man nicht da hinten.
Die Spuren
sollen Aufschluss darüber geben,
wieso das Auto im Graben landete.
Keiner trug einen Gurt.
Die sind
in einem ganz normalen Zustand.
Das muss aber nichts heissen.
D.h., dass die Kollision
nicht so stark war,
obwohl es so aussieht.
Ich habe hier
ein Absperrband angebracht.
So sieht man,
dass wir schon hier waren.
Der Abschleppdienst ist eingetroffen.
Er sagt, er habe Gas gegeben,
und dann brach das Auto langsam aus.
Als er rutschte,
begann er zu bremsen.
Und dann knallte er
links in die Absperrung.
Hat der Lenker
das Fahrzeug nicht beherrscht?
Oder war es schlicht ein Unfall,
der jedem passieren könnte?
Wenn du weisst, wo er gelandet ist,
dann siehst du hier,
wie er reingeknallt ist.
Im Büro fangen die Polzisten an,
ihre Fotos auszuwerten.
Es ist so fotografiert,
dass man praktisch der Spur folgt.
Genau. Wir haben hier begonnen.
Aber was du gut siehst,
was hier wichtig war,
ist die Kurve.
Von der Profildicke her kam das Auto
eigentlich nicht ins Rutschen.
D.h, er ist nicht
in die Kurve gefahren
und hat diesen gemacht.
Sonst hätte es hier
eine breite Schleifspur.
Es ist natürlich
sehr eindrücklich zu sehen,
wie alles funktioniert.
Und das jetzt einmal vor Ort.
Man sieht das
in der Regel sehr selten.
Vom Grossteil bin ich ...
Ich denke schon, dass es so ist,
wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Ich war überrascht,
wie viele Dinge es zu beachten gibt
und wie viele Faktoren mitspielen.
Im Grossen und Ganzen
wurden meine Erwartungen erfüllt.
Und so geht es weiter.
Schau zu mir!
Zu mir schauen, Jana.
Jana Stierli kommt im 3 °C
kalten Wasser an ihre Grenzen.
* Klopfen *
- Herr Burgener?
Und Nando Wüthrich
wird mit dem Tod konfrontiert.
Oh, da liegt jemand.
Wir haben alles abgesperrt
und warten auf den Arzt.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Liz Lei - 2021